waskie gueule ça ne vous dit peut-être
rien et pourtant c'est un obnl un
organisme à but non lucratif présent
partout au québec c'est près de 2000
logements sociaux pour les autochtones
et les métis qui veulent vivre hors des
réserves juste à dolbeau mistassini il y
en a plus de trois cents c'est là que se
trouve le siège social de la west guns
certains la voient comme un modèle de
réussite autochtone au service de sa
communauté
mais notre enquête raconte une toute
autre histoire
des rénovations importantes qui tarde à
se faire on faisait des petites
réparations mais heroes serait pas la
sueur aux unités de combat y avait des
fondations mais est-il souvent un tour
social n des dirigeants qui se servent
de l'organisme à but non lucratif pour
s'enrichir sans conflit d'intérêt donc
deux premiers niveaux très bien dans ça
c'est clair qu on ait autant du côté du
fournisseur que du côté du client
des gens qui ont peur de parler mais pas
tellement voix spectateurs aujourd'hui
suite à table et peu disposé des red
sein deux paliers de gouvernements qui
tolèrent la situation depuis des années
et des locataires laissés à eux mêmes
il ya à se poser de sérieuses questions
comment ça marche la mosquée gagné
habitat médecins n'ont quel pouvoir
raison pour qu'on est pauvre qu'on n'est
pas des êtres comme ça
moi ce qui égale ses 50 ans d'histoire
racontée dans ce livre si le bâtisseur
de la loi ce qui gaine fernand chalifoux
qui recrutent gilles dérobé au milieu
des années 80 sans scolarité ni
expérience du monde des affaires il
devient le leader
le pdg d'outox gun gilles bérubé a
toujours dit être métisse son but
améliorer la qualité de vie les siens
aujourd'hui on est certes les
organisations autochtones vivant aura
peut-être environ 1000 personnes
ensemble chalifoux et bérubé vont bâtir
un empire
aujourd'hui gilles bérubé est un des
hommes d'affaires les plus influents à
dolbeau mistassini parfois actionnaire
unique parfois copropriétaires ses
actifs présents ou passés sont visibles
par tout juste dans cette petite
localité de 14 mille habitants le pdg de
la wac et guns possède deux centres
commerciaux une résidence pour personnes
âgées et plusieurs immeubles à logements
il y à sa maison au bord de la rivière
mistassini le garage qui abritait ni le
capteur et l'écurie qu'il possède avec
sa fille une fortune amassée en partie
avec de l'argent public
cet homme ne soit pas être identifiée la
caméra parce qu'il craint pour son
emploi il occupait des fonctions
importantes au sein de l'organisation
il connaît bien le président bérubé bien
sûr il a utilisé son argent personnel
mais son influence les avantages qu'ils
pouvaient chercher de west guns en
termes de relations d'affaires presque
incestueux dans certains cas lui ont
clairement donné un avantage comparatif
que d'autres n'auront jamais par exemple
ce prêt de 400 mille dollars accordés
paroisse qui égaye à la galerie des
érables un des centres commerciaux de
gilles bérubé
certaines de ces entreprises reçoivent
aussi régulièrement des contrats de
l'eau bnl gilles personnellement est
impliqué dans plusieurs entreprises qui
faisait affaire avec wasquehal gun des
membres de sa famille également
ils tirent un avantage pécunier de faire
affaire avec que wasquehal gun dans un
premier échange de courriels avec gilles
bérubé
il a nié ces informations il affirme que
ces entreprises n'ont jamais eu de liens
d'affaires pécuniaire avec la
corporation osk et guns & habitat mitis
du nord waskie guînes c'est un réseau
complexe de bnl où les mêmes
administrateurs se retrouve pratiquement
partout mais c'est aussi des entreprises
privées sur lesquelles président bérubé
à la mainmise la corporation aesc eagle
gère le parc immobilier mais ces
habitats métisse du nord qui possède la
majorité des logements sociaux qui
reçoit les subventions ce qui m'étonne
c'est qu'il y en ait autant messaoud
abda est un expert en matière de
gouvernance des tic et de criminalité
financière
l'idée de ce genre de structure qui
n'est pas une équipe dont exceptionnel
abbas khan donc c'est un modèle connu
l'île et d'avoir des obnl puis beaucoup
d'entreprises la tue c'est de pouvoir
ventiler la sortie des fonds d eau bnl
vers des entreprises privées pour que
les dirigeants puissent récupérer
l'argent
les entreprises appartenant à wasquehal
gueule oeuvre généralement dans le
domaine de l'habitation mélo bnl possède
aussi un resto-bar commerce de pièces
d'autos et même une pourvoirie des
entreprises toujours administrée par
gilles bérubé fernand chalifoux et
quelques membres de leur cercle
rapproché les documents administratifs
de wasquehal gun était tellement enrobés
et généraux qu'il était dur de détecter
tous ces mouvements d'argent
maintenant vous allez me dire mais même
chabasse s'ils déclarent leurs revenus
oui mais ce serait extrêmement rare que
qu'un dirigeant ou des dirigeants soient
aussi aussi aussi transparent avec avec
les agences du revenu quand il exécute
ce genre de stratagème pour savoir si
l'argent public sert bien les locataires
nous sommes allés leur rendre visite des
gens satisfaits
nous en avons rencontré mais chez ce
locataire
il ya de la moisissure autour des
fenêtres et les plafonds sont arrachés
depuis des mois en raison de fuites
d'eau on se croirait
il y avait des gâteaux long du mur
thérèse gauthier demeure dans un
appartement d'habitat métisse du nord à
l'hiver 2010 est il y a trop de neige
sur le toit et la structure de la maison
montre des signes inquiétants
madame gauthier avizois siegen mais
personne ne donne suite à ces appels
quand enfin contremaître se présente
chez elle il m'écoutait madame gauthier
avenger de cinq pièces cfa ok j 10 midi
là vous aurez passé une belle pièce une
dis-moi g14 ça est 500 pour vous faire
les plus grosses eu pourtant cette même
année habitat métisse du nord a reçu 14
points 5 millions de dollars des deux
paliers de gouvernement dont plus de six
millions pour faire des travaux dans les
logements avec des amis thérèse gauthier
réalise les travaux elle-même elle
estime avoir dépensé près de 3000
dollars de l'argent qu'elle n'avait pas
si aujourd'hui j'ai décidé de dénoncer
c'est que je le fais pour moi mais je le
fais collectivement aussi parce qu'il ya
des gens qui souffrent énormément
qui sont elles qui sont dans des hlm de
la corporation etc sont laissés à
eux-mêmes pour comprendre vous vont
réellement les fonds publics direction
dolbeau mistassini
ici tout le monde connaît bien la
famille du pdg gilles bérubé une famille
que la mosquée guen a divisé
[Musique]
fernand c'est un des cadets de la
famille bérubé son mandat faire des
travaux dans la maison privée de son
frère payer paroisse qui est jeune jake
folle à la coopération ip ago pour
l'entreprise
c'était en plus fernand demeure
gratuitement dans un appartement
d'habitat métisse du nord alors que les
locataires doivent donner 25 % de leurs
revenus ils risquent gros en nous
parlant
coïncidence ou non fernand reçoit ce
message texte de son frère gilles juste
avant notre entrevue il écrit fernand
c'est important de se parler
j'ai été correct avec toi appelle moi
avant qu'il soit trop tard on revient
une affirmation me suis creusé par du
monde qui a on dirait un peu pompeux
pour rien fait ou qu'on présente ya but
d' annuler pouvoir
moi je reste dans son appartement si je
vais ça nous amène tout droit formation
à dolbeau mistassini une véritable
omerta s'est créé autour de wasquehal
gun et de son pdg gilles bérubé
les gens ont peur de parler ses trois
autres frères de gilles ont hésité
longtemps
on avait peur on avait peur des
représailles ont toutes les menaces
jacques bérubé a déjà été partenaire
d'affaires avec gilles il possède des
documents démontrant que le pdg de la
west guns utilisent l'argent de l'eau
bnl comme bon lui semble pour l'achat
d'une pelle mécanique par exemple on a
acheté une pelle à sam était prêt à lui
fait du chemin en forêt suite au sommet
je dis aux allées à bavay après et non
voile pretty s'était fâché de sa amidala
le che qui fit le provenaient de la
biomédecine à retravailler matin un
point d'eau j'ai arrêté en 2012 - riber
main puis y'a des fois contre eux mais
estime de moi et ce taux
tu vois pas raison mais permettent à
notre adresse jacquot oui ici par le
colloque auquel personne ne te laisses
en réalité gérard départ est des
logements appartenant personnellement à
gilles bérubé et constater que
qu'apparaît taylor mais gilbert dubé
mais moi je savais pas que ce terre
c'était de l'eau maire et gilbert oui
j'avais fini dans ce secteur que il m
est en fait moins c'est ce que vous
trouvez vous ma pays bas c'est sûr que
si tu vas pas de pays maghrébins avec
famille et amis un gorille à pile à eau
baisse et 7 vous c'est à quelle adresse
que tous ces bras 6
parfois ce sont même les matériaux payé
par l'eau bnl que le président bérubé a
utilisé à ses propres fins gaston a
siégé sur le ca d'habitat métisse du
nord on prend des décisions et par
contre a suggéré par agelou a proposé
par à part gilles ça fait que vu juste
après ben non on appuyait est ce que
vous aviez qu'il l'avait un peu le
contrôle français d'administration
prenait les décisions prix vous appuyez
sur où exactement
les membres du conseil d'administration
étaient spécifiquement sélectionnées
notamment au regard de leur fidélité
envers monsieur bérubé monsieur
chalifoux c'était aussi des gens qui
étaient par revendicateurs puisqu'il
faut facilement manipulable rita cahier
habite un logement d'habitat métisse du
nord elle a vu le président bérubé à
l'oeuvre manipulate en émettant il y
avait la résolution que il faut me
saisit financiers il ya parmi ceux-là
y aller au micro qui influença les
membres il est toujours en cours tout le
temps à toutes les années quelque chose
de quelqu'un qui actions ou lui action
jacques bérubé est un de ceux qui a eu
plusieurs démêlés juridiques avec la
corporation ask again et son président
il dénonce la situation depuis longtemps
aujourd'hui l'homme est épuisée par
toutes ces batailles
il souhaite que d'autres prennent la
parole publiquement les rêves crise se
trouve qu'il disait me défrise met à
table
si con ray mabus
corey may de la vue parce que ribéry
mail si tout s'est fait prendre les
affaires des autres
c'est impossible de se battre machine
demande que la redite à part de l'ouest
qui y viennent pour se défendre la part
de docteurs disent nos apports de ces
peu
des organismes qui ont de l'argent nous
autres on est seulement un salaire il
faut près faudra être riche pour canal
de ce bateau nous ce système non
[Musique]
au début des années 90 les besoins de
logement décent pour les autochtones
vivant hors des réserves son grain les
gouvernements accordent des sommes
importantes pour corriger la situation
waskie guen organisme à but non lucratif
de dolbeau mistassini a le vent dans les
voiles
mais on doit dire facilement qu'on enfin
autour de 200 à 250 logements par année
et si on enfin chiffre peut-être 15
millions rien ne semble freiner
l'ambition des bâtisseurs de la wes
cates jusqu'en 1994
radio canada a appris que la sûreté du
québec enquête sur des irrégularités
dans la gestion de subvention donnée par
ottawa et québec à des subventions de
113 millions sans aucun contrôle
on soupçonne entre autres le patron des
deux organismes en question la société
wascat egan et habitat métisse du nord
d'avoir profité de ses subventions là on
y parle de conflit d'intérêts
d'informations erronées de matériaux de
construction acheté à dolbeau et
transporté à joliette ou encore à pointe
aux trembles
gilles bérubé est montré du doigt à
l'époque j'étais ministre des affaires
municipales mais également ministre
responsable de l'habitation
rémy trudel se souvient très bien de la
west guns je pouvais pas rendre compte à
l'assemblée nationale de façon claire et
transparente de ce qui se passait dans
ces organismes là quant au million que
l'on consacré la corporation wascat
aiguines en 1991 a fait pays à la
société d'habitation du québec 53
projets de rénovation d'urgence
les vérificateurs note que la
photographie de la même bâtisse figurait
dans 14 des dossiers
[Musique]
plus de 400 chefs d'accusation de fraude
et vol sont déposés au palais de justice
de roberval contre wasquehal gueule ses
filiales et certains collaborateurs
mais en 1996 surprise
deux juges rejettent les accusations
criminelles au stade de l'enquêté
préliminaire
les preuves sont insuffisantes pour
tenir un procès peu importe le ministre
trudel lui passent à l'action
j'ai décidé de modifier la loi pour
qu'on puisse avoir éventuellement des
représentants sur ces organismes lot de
façon à ce que nous puissions avoir les
résultats de l'utilisation des sommes
accordées son projet de loi est adoptée
en 1998
tout juste avant que rémy trudel ne
changent de ministère mais notre enquête
montre qu'aucun représentant du
gouvernement n'a siégé sur le ca
d'habitat métisse du nord par la suite
je n'ai pas l'explication toujours
pertinent que la société d'habitation du
québec plus nommer des membres du
conseil d'administration pour s'assurer
du respect des processus
la suite des événements est favorable
aux présidents des rup et il va empocher
beaucoup d'argent wasquehal gun d'autres
entités du groupe et certains
administrateurs contre attaque
il poursuivra shq pour atteinte à leur
réputation après des années de démêlés
juridiques les parties en arrivent à une
entente à l'amiable
la ffq verse près de 6 millions de
dollars habitat métisse du nord via
différents programmes et 450 me et là
des administrateurs de l'eau bnl jamais
vu dans l'histoire de la shq à lui seul
gilles bérubé embauchera 365 milles
dollars
mais ça ne s'arrête pas là bérubé
demande à son ca de lui verser 390 mille
dollars supplémentaires à même les fonds
d'habitat métisse du nord il prétend
faussement que la shq a autorisé ce
versement
le ca accepte de verser la somme c'est
un homme très stratégique qui fonctionne
beaucoup avec son tiff x est très bien
placé ses pions au bon endroit il un
contrôle absolu sur le message il peut
agir à sa guise dans ces conditions là
au moment d'encaisser l'argent
gilles bérubé annonce qu'il quitte son
poste de pdg ce n'est pas 3 190 mille
dollars qu'il reçoit mais plutôt un demi
million de dollars
le prétexte une prime de départ lié à
une clause de non-concurrence messaoud
abda ne s'explique pas comment le
gouvernement plus tolérer une telle
situation
t on est dans les eaux bnl
on est dans le service à la communauté
on est dans l'aide au développement dans
la réduction de la pauvreté dans on est
on est dans le développement social bien
tu vois la part du gouvernement mais
heureusement écoute qui va vous dire
qu'il parte le dirigeant c'est un obnl
on peut avoir quelqu'un d'autre la place
gilles bérubé ne quittera jamais la
mosquée gueule il est encore le pdg
aujourd'hui lui et fernand chalifoux on
refusait de témoigner à la caméra dans
un courriel que le pdg nous envoyer il
dit mes relations avec la corporation
sont du domaine privé et ne vous
concerne pas
aujourd'hui des métis mécontents
réclament des changements à la direction
de la mosquée gun une trentaine d'entre
eux se sont réunis en janvier dernier à
val d'or et le mouvement prend de
l'ampleur
rita kgs et faisait partie de ce groupe
qui s'ouvre et yeux qu'il faut et ce
mécontentement ne date pas d'hier
en 2006 des centaines de medicis avaient
signé une pétition réclamant que le
gouvernement ouvre une enquête publique
la société d'habitation du québec n'a
pas voulu commenter publiquement dans ce
message la shq répond le lien qui permet
de faire une vérification administrative
existe uniquement avec habitat métisse
du nord et non avec la corporation west
guns
l'une de ces vérifications
administratives a été effectuée en 2006
nous avons obtenu copie du rapport
interne
les constats apparence de conflit
d'intérêts
entente administrative non respectés
logements sous-occupés profits
importants
année après année
[Musique]
tellement profits qu'en 2012 habitat
métisse du nord un surplus de 3,4
millions de dollars dans son fond
d'économie de gestion plutôt que de
diminuer leurs subventions
la shq leur demande de dépenser l'argent
rapidement
j'ai bien vécu toute la commission
charbonneau toutes les ai tous les
événements que vous avez vues dans le
secteur de la construction où des gens
étaient clairement conflits d'intérêts
puis coup on a décidé qu'on a un statut
que c'est inacceptable
puis on a pris les mesures pour et même
des sanctions du côté fédéral
la société canadienne d'hypothèques et
de logement a elle aussi refusé nos
demandes d'entrevue
joint au téléphone ce responsable du
tout simplement faire confiance aux
organismes on sait désormais fabriqué
une bombe pour messaoud abda régler ses
problèmes de gouvernance hawass qui
gaine et choses simples les
fonctionnaires en ont le pouvoir
vous regardez la mission d'obnl vous
regardez comment ces dirigeants exécute
le la mission de bnl vous avez la
conclusion qu'il n'est plus apte qui ne
se qualifie plus vous a pas besoin
d'aller dans les tribunaux s'est passé
votre jugement voulu donner c'est un
privilège que je peux retirer son dans
certaines conditions
depuis qu'ils ont perdu la bataille
juridique en 1995
les dirigeants de la shq crainte d'être
poursuivis à nouveau écouter ils l'ont
fait une fois dans les années 1995 2000
et ça aboutit à rien alors que c'était
extrêmement flagrant le dossier waskie
guen est une véritable patate chaude
puis il ya la question qui n'est
toujours pas réglé sur le plan politique
qui est ou n'est pas métis quand nous
avons posé la question au frère de
gilles bérubé leurs réponses évasives
avait attiré notre attention en automne
mais homonyme et quand on s'est rendu
compte qu'on se faisait contrer dié pour
en avoir le coeur net nous avons
présenté à ce chercheur en généalogie le
livre sur la wasquehal gun on peut y
lire que sa mère florence grimard serait
autochtone merci mais s'ils spéculent
dans cette écoute et sa grand mère
toutefois lorsqu'on fait la vérification
avec les registres paroissiaux sont tous
publics et disponibles indiquent
pourtant il y en a pas mis aucune
mention
quelqu'un fait un acteur pour prouver sa
ligne autochtone gilles bérubé a utilisé
une copie du certificat de naissance de
sa mère nous avons obtenu ce document il
est inscrit qu elle est née sur une
réserve autochtone ci est écrit que la
personne saine et à point bleu n'est pas
né à pointe bleue on peut l'observer ici
c'est le registre de roberval pardon
quand je regarde ce document ça serait
intéressant de le faire vérifier par le
bas par un avocat ou un notaire avec le
clergé
parce qu'il sent que ce document là
aient été modifiées ou qu'il ya une
erreur
éric pouliot tisdale a fait la
généalogie de la famille bérubé jusque
dans les années 1600 puis finalement la
motive car en france pour tous les pères
est absolument certain
lorsque questionné à propos de ceux qui
s'autoproclament autochtone bérubé
répondait ceci malheureusement vous
savez il ya des profiteurs du système
malheureusement
gilles bérubé y aurait donc trompé tout
le monde sur ses origines pendant plus
de 38 ans c'est nous qui les faisons
vivre s'ils avaient pour nous pour les
fait revivre il y en aurait besoin
d'acheter bio n'avait pas de travail je
sais c'est ce point qui comprime ou site
et
[Musique]